تصدر التيار الصدري الانتخابات التشريعيه
العراقيه التي جرت في اكتوبر العام الماضي
بحصوله على 73 مقعدا
وحلت قائمه التحالف تقدم في المركز الثاني
بس 37 مقعدا تلتها قائمه دوله القانون بث
ل 33 ثم الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني ب31
مقعدا وحصل التحالف الفتح على 17 مقعدا
مما تحالف عزم ففاس باربعه عشر مقعدا
وفاسر مستقلون في 43
ساعه الصدر الى تشكيل حكومه اغلبيه وهو ما
عارضه الاطار التنسيقي الذي دعا الى تشكيل
حكومه توافقيه في الثانيه عشر من يونيو
اعلن زعيم التيار الصدري استقاله وبه من
البرلمان بعد الفشل في تشكيل الحكومه
افراد ذلك فعلنا الاطار التنسيقي وانه
اصبح الكتله البرلمانيه الاكثر عددا بعد
ان تم ترشيح وبجدد بدلا عن النواب
المستقيمين
نجح التنسيقي في تشكيل تحالف اغلبيه بعد
استماره حلفاء الصدر السابقين من السنه
والاكراد ليؤدي ذلك الى انتخاب رئيس
الجمهوريه ورئيس الوزراء